Hey everyone.
We work with Bayer, a big pharma
company, to build a novel system that I
want to talk to you about today. We
built a hypothesis research system for
hypothesis generation in drug discovery.
So Bayer team came to us to ask for an
agentic system that would allow them to
build and iterate on the corpus of
research they already have to predict
the areas where their scientists should
focus. There was just too much data and
they needed a memory system to pinpoint
and locate where is the interesting area
for research for their agentic
workflows. This is not just a pure
search problem. The Bayer team needed to
effectively understand in which area the
hypothesis generation and the scientific
discovery should continue and in which
area it's not relevant. And for to do
that, Cogni's team needed to understand
together with Bayer very specific domain
of biomedical research, iterate on it,
validate it, and then predict the area
of where this future improvements can
happen. And to do that, we've solved
that by building a custom agentic
research system that allows Bayer's
agent to use Cogni's memory layer to
predict the areas of research the
scientists should focus on and thus
reduce the time the scientists would
take themselves to do this type of
operation themselves. Imagine reading
10,000 scientific papers. I'm sure they
enjoy it, but to a degree that gets
quite tricky and quite extensive. So
what we've done is we've ingested the
data, we've structured the knowledge
using formal traditional ontologies in
combination with that LM generated
knowledge. And then, together with that,
we built a system that is fully
explainable that allows us to validate
on synthetic data set and cross-validate
on the real data sets on how this
data moves and behaves and performs and
especially these new novel predictions
we are building. This is our
breakthrough innovation this this area
of where we are kind of focusing the
direction forward and you can see here
that we did both the ingested generated
and shuffled data cross validation and
then cross domain validation and we've
shown effectively significant results
that we'll publish in a paper we are
working together with buyer where we are
already preparing the poster that should
be published in a couple of days. So
this is effectively something that
allows buyers team to reduce the human
time. Imagine a team of researchers just
browsing through this paper trying to
automate parts of the entity extraction
and memory consolidation and what we try
to do here is we try to really build
this in a way that the teams there can
use it in an automated fashion and
iterate on it and understand it. So
we've molded this into a repeatable
motion. We can run this with other
customers. We have this know-how on how
to really do this on deep graph
embedding level where we can predict
this type of
relationships and interesting areas not
for just buyer but any anywhere else.
And if you're interested let us know. In
a sense this is something where we've
definitely contributed to buyers team
but also to Cognizant's open source by
learning building and iterating with
them to get this project done.